Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 35,
am Mikrofon Tim Pridlaff und wir machen weiter mit frischen Themen und heute
haben wir was ganz Besonderes auf der Liste.
Diesmal geht es nicht um Technik, sondern um Kultur, aber dann auch wieder um Technik.
Das Thema ist heute Perry Roden.
Ja, Chaos Radio Express.
Wir haben uns erholt von der Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft und heute ist das Thema
auch nicht mehr die WM, sondern wie schon gesagt Perry Roden.
Ein Name, den sicherlich jeder schon mal gehört hat. Ist so ein bisschen wie
Beate Uwe, jeder kennt den Namen.
Aber im Gegensatz zu Beate Uwe hat glaube ich auch nicht unbedingt jeder eine
klare Vorstellung davon, was das ist.
Ich erinnere mich selber immer noch daran, dass es mir immer so ein bisschen
unklar war, was ich mir eigentlich genau darunter vorstellen muss.
Aber eigentlich waren das ja diese Heftchen.
Mit mir ist jetzt Gregor, Gregor Sedlak. Hallo, Gregor.
Kannst du mich hören? Hallo, Tim. Ich kann dich hören.
Super. Ich möchte da gleich einhaken. Oh, du möchtest sofort einhaken.
Ich wollte dich noch kurz vorstellen, Gregor.
Du bist Du bist ja selber in diesem Perioden-Universum ein Mitstreiter und ein
langjähriger Fan, da können wir auch gleich nochmal im Detail drauf eingehen,
aber das kannst du ja schon mal einhaken.
Also die phonetische Aussprache, die offizielle ist,
obwohl Perry Rodan ein amerikanischer Staatsbürger gewesen ist,
da es eine deutsche Weltraumserie allerdings ist, nennen wir den Menschen Perry Rodan.
Und ich hab Rodan gesagt.
Genau.
Oh ja.
Das ist nicht falsch, aber.
Okay, aber das ist genau diese Illusion. Aber es kommt ja auch aus der Zeit
dieser ersten Heftromane in den 60er Jahren.
Perry Rodenton ist 1961 gestartet worden als Serie.
Da gab es dann auch so andere Heftromane, so wie Jerry Cotton und überhaupt
generell war es ja total hip mit...
Mit englischen Namen zu arbeiten.
Ja, also der Heftroman selber ist, wie ich es gerne bezeichnen möchte,
ein diskretes Massenmedium.
Allerdings direkt nach dem Krieg waren die Ressourcen knapp und der Hunger nach
Unterhaltung und Literatur groß und der Heftroman billig im Rotationsdruck auf
billigsten Palppapier zu erzeugen,
sehr populär und auch gerade für,
breiteste Bevölkerungsschichten zugänglich und wurde durch die Bank gelesen
mit Periroden ist wahrscheinlich schon so eine zweite und dritte Welle,
wo also durch das Serienprinzip schon versucht worden ist in so einer Marketingmaßnahme
eine stärkere Leserbindung zu begründen.
Was ist Periroden oder Rodan? Habe ich Periroden gesagt?
Ich glaube du hast Periroden gesagt.
Das ist schlimm. Bitte. Der bericht mich sofort, sollte ich nochmal Peri Rodan sagen.
Okay, ich hab dich wahrscheinlich angestiftet. Also Peri Rodan ist also ein,
aber trotzdem ist er amerikanischer Staatsbürger, das passt ja irgendwie nicht zusammen.
Peri Rodan ist in seinem Paralleluniversum der erste Mann auf dem Mond.
Gewesen. Also der Neil Armstrong des Periversums heißt Perry Rodan und der ist
mit seiner Crew der ersten Mondlander-Expedition,
mit der Stardust dort gelandet und ist gleich in ein Abwehrsystem eines dort
notgelandeten archonidischen Forschungskreuzers hängen geblieben.
Okay, jetzt steigen wir schon sehr in diese Universumswelt ein,
das wollen wir ja auch machen, aber ich wollte das nochmal kurz zusammenfassen,
wovon wir also eigentlich reden.
Also Perry Die Rodan ist eine Heftserie, gab's für wenig Groschen,
für wenig Pfennig an jedem Kiosk zu kaufen.
Und ist dann wie häufig erschienen? Also wie regelmäßig ist das erschienen?
Also seit dem 8. September 1961 haben sie es geschafft, jede Woche ein Heft zu publizieren.
Jede Woche ein Heft? Und die waren dann wie dick?
Das sind, ich glaube 68 oder mit Umschlag 72 Seiten.
Der Textumfang hängt so ein bisschen davon ab, wie die Laufweite eingestellt wird.
Also manchmal scheint es so gewesen zu sein, dass das Manuskript nicht alles
abgedeckt hätte und dann wird mal ein bisschen mehr Platz gelassen.
Aber jedes Heft hat im Prinzip eine abgeschlossene Geschichte?
Kann man das so sagen? Oder gab es auch so Fortsetzungsgeschichten?
Wie ist das? Ist das so wie unsere Fernsehserien, wo es dann immer weitergeht
mit so einem Cliffhanger?
Ja, also das Prinzip ist erstmal im Vergleich zum normalen Groschen,
Arzt und Jerry-Cotton-Heft eben,
dass Perry Roden eine Art Telenovela-Prinzip hat,
eine,
lang,
geplante,
und,
in langen, oft mehrere hunderte von Wänden sich abspulende,
Handlung,
durch,
ein Autorenteam,
gefertigt,
wird.
Und natürlich jeder Heftroman ein gewisses Kapitel dieser großen Geschichte trägt.
Aber es war ja nicht von Anfang an so geplant, dass es so ein Monster wird.
Doch, also auf dem ersten Periodenheft steht,
Also als, ähm, heute würde man sagen Vision-Statement, dass Perry Roden in eine
ferne Zukunft führt, in der die Erde nur noch ein verlassener Planet ist,
der um eine erloschene oder erl ...
Erl ... nennt man das, wenn eine Sonne gerade erlischt?
Um eine erloschene Sonne. Scherbler Schwan.
Ein Planet, der um eine erloschene Sonne kreist. Mhm.
Und auch die Tech-9 von Perry Roden, die heute nicht mehr so eingesetzt wird,
lautete damals bis in die 70er, 80er Jahre der Erbe des Universums.
Stimmt, hab ich auch gelesen.
Und das war auch so gemeint.
Aha.
Man hat es allerdings die ersten 20 Jahre nicht verstanden.
Achso. Das heißt, dass das Universum als solches irgendwie dann dahin schwindet
und dann gibt es ein anderes oder?
Dass der Handlungsbogen so weit fortschreitet, dass gewissermaßen das gesamte
Universum in den Regelungs- und Kontrollbereich unseres Helden fällt. Mhm.
Und was für einen Zeitraum decken jetzt die Geschichten ab? Also,
ist das kontinuierlich bis in
die Zukunft oder wird da auch mal in die Vergangenheit zurückgesprungen?
Ja, also, der momentane Handlungsablauf, der so dokumentiert ist,
umfasst mehrere Millionen Jahre.
Also ich glaube das geht bis 20 Millionen Jahre in die Vergangenheit und naturgemäß
in die Zukunft ist es immer ein bisschen schwierig Prognosen in die Zukunft zu machen.
Aber Periodon ist sozusagen immer noch dabei?
Ja.
Weil er unsterblich ist?
Perioden ist dann relativ schnell auch relativ unsterblich geworden,
was heißt, dass er lange lebt, aber nicht unverwundbar ist.
Ahh, okay, dann sollten wir jetzt
vielleicht mal so ein bisschen auf die Ursprünge der Geschichte kommen.
Was, wie geht das los und worum geht es?
Genau, also die Exposition ist, finde ich, sehr schön und schnell zu erklären.
Die erste Mondlande-Expedition trifft beim Betreten des Mondes auf eine schon dort befindliche,
sehr fortgeschrittene Weltraumzivilisation, die eine Panne hatte und gewissermaßen
am Mond notgelandet ist.
Und es kommt zu einem Kontakt. Die Außerirdischen, die übrigens menschenähnlich
sind und Alkoniden heißen,
bitten die Menschen um medizinische und andere Sekundärrohstoffhilfe an,
weil sie sind ein bisschen zu verpeilt, um noch alles so richtig regeln zu können.
Die sind auf dem Mond.
Die sind da auf dem Mond gelandet, weil sie nicht auf der Erde landen durften,
weil sie sich dann ja gewissermaßen einer niederen Zivilisation offenbart hätten
und das wollten sie nicht, aber sie wollten da in der Nähe bleiben.
Und der Perioden nutzt die Chance, dass er sieht,
dass da eine sehr überlegene Technologie in seine Hände fallen könnte,
mit der er etwas verhindern will, was wirklich sehr tragisch gewesen wäre zu der Zeit.
Nämlich, dass in der Heftserie zwei Machtblöcke quasi kurz vorm Atomkrieg gegeneinander
gerüstet kurz davor waren loszuschlagen.
Und das ist eine schöne Parallele zu der Zeit damals 61, das war die Kuba-Krise,
der absolute Höhepunkt des Kalten Krieges, der kurz vorm Heißlaufen war und,
als solche eine Hintergrundfolie für diese Hefte gegeben hat,
die absolut realistisch und für die DESAN nachvollziehbar war.
Kann man sagen, dass dann Perioden auch generell als Reflektion auf die Realität gedacht war?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es gedacht war, aber es war in jedem Fall,
in diesem Kontext kann es nur so gesehen werden.
Und ganz kurz noch die, ich will nur nochmal die Exposition ganz kurz zu Ende bringen.
Der Perioden nimmt also diese überlegene Technologie,
auch durch seine Kühnheit und Keckheit nimmt er in Anspruch und baut sich auf
dem Landeplatz, wo er zurückkehrt mit seiner Mondrakete,
so ein eigenes kleines Territorium in der Wüste Gobi auf und die anderen Atommachtblöcke
finden das erstmal nicht so lustig, aber einen großen...
Energieschirm und die anderen können erstmal nichts machen und mit der Zeit
erkennen sie an, dass es da einen neuen Machtfaktor im internationalen Geschehen gibt,
etwa so groß wie Monaco, aber unbesiegbar und dann wird er eingeladen in die
UNO und darf sich also völkerrechtlich einbringen und das ist so die Kernzelle
für eine spätere Weltrepublik,
die dann Perioden gewissermaßen anstößt durch diesen Prozess.
Das dauert dann noch ein paar Dutzend Romane, aber dann ist im Prinzip das erste
Ziel, eine geeinte Menschheit zu erreichen, in der Heftserie vollzogen.
A. Das heißt, dreht sich dann alles im Prinzip da drum?
Also er sitzt dann wieder in Monaco und ist die dritte Machtzentre,
das ist einfach nur der Start.
Weil diese Außerirdischen, die hatten eine Mission, die da in Not gelandet waren,
die suchten nämlich nach dem ewigen Leben.
Und das haben sie aber nicht gefunden und sie haben es jetzt auch bitter nötig,
das ewige Leben zu finden, weil sie ja schon so im Abstieg befindliches Großimperium sind.
Also sie sitzen da gerade so auf dem Mond und rollten vor sich hin.
Ja, aber sie wollten eigentlich einen Planeten finden, der ganz in der Nachbarschaft
eigentlich angesiedelt ist, nämlich im Vega-System und der Perioden geht dann
mit seinen inzwischen arkonidischen Freunden,
fliegt er dann dahin und dann machen die so ein, es nennt sich das kosmische,
Rätsel, das ist also so ein großes Abenteuer-Rätsel,
von,
Planet zu Planet, springen sie da von einem Rätsel zum anderen und hinterher zum,
Schluss gibt es halt eine große Frage und Aufgabe und dann steht also das ewige
Leben offen in Form einer sogenannten Zelldusche,
die erstmal die Lebenserwartung um 70 Jahre verlängert, indem einfach die biologischen
Alterungsprozesse eingefroren werden.
Und die Überraschung ist, dass die Wesenheit, die diesen Apparat bedient und
dieses Rätsel ausgelegt hat, jetzt auf einmal sagt, nein, nein,
liebe Arkoniden, ihr habt das zwar gesucht,
aber dem, dem ich diese Lebensverlängerung eigentlich zuteilen will,
das ist der Peri Rodanda von den Terranern.
Die scheinen mir jünger und noch hungrig und aufstrebensbereit und die sollen
das jetzt mal für die nächsten 20.000 Jahre erledigen.
Da kommt eine Menge Arbeit auf sie zu. Und ich werde sie dazu dann immer mal anrufen.
Was ist das für eine Wesenheit, die das jetzt sozusagen unter seiner Kontrolle hat?
Jetzt kommen wir schon zu den,
zu der etwas größeren Zusammenhängen der Periodenserie. Diese Wesenheit.
Wurde ursprünglich eingeführt unter dem Namen Wanderer oder auch S. S wie in Über-S.
Also IS.
Aber wird S ausgesprochen. Inzwischen weiß man etwas über die Hintergründe, wie S entstanden ist.
Ich würde einfach sagen, es ist ein ständiger Begleiter der Menschheit,
ist aber in unserer Galaxis und in den anliedernden
Galaxis so als der Hintergrundmachtfaktor tätig und hat auch eine Menge Aufgaben
auf universaler und transuniversaler Ebene als Superintelligenz zu tun und braucht
hin und wieder gewissermaßen die ganzirdischen Wesenheiten,
um bestimmte Aufgaben zu erfüllen.
Dazu kommt, dass das Periversum in einem Zwiebelschalenmodell von evolutionären
Prozessen aufgegliedert ist,
wo dann vom Einzeller zum Mehrzeller zum Säugetier zur Superintelligenz und
dann darüber stehenden Entitäten namens Kosmokraten und Chaotarchen da so eine
Evolutionsleiter besteht.
Und jede dieser Wesenheiten hat in ihrem Zuständigkeitsbereich bestimmte Kompetenzen
und auch Nichtkompetenzen,
die dazu führen, dass sie manchmal auch auf niedriger Ebene sich gar nicht adäquat
artikulieren können und müssen
dann auf Hilfsvölker oder auf andere Supportmaßnahmen zurückgreifen.
Also Wesenheit ist jetzt eher ein allgemeiner Begriff, den du jetzt gerade gewählt
hast oder der so da auch verwendet wird?
Der ist jetzt sehr allgemein, wird aber durchaus verwendet, aber Superintelligenz
ist gewissermaßen das ja ist dann der Begriff,
der jetzt offiziell für die nächst über den Terranern und vergleichbaren Völkern
stehende Einheit und der Prozess zur Superintelligenz entsteht durch so eine
Machtkonzentration, einer technologischen Entwicklung,
die hinterher zu einer Vergeistigung führt,
dass man sich die meisten Völker, die sich diese Schwelle zur Superintelligenz
dann mal überschritten haben,
verlassen also des körperlichen Seinszusammenhang und versuchen eine Geistwesen
zu werden und haben dann also einen entsprechend hohen Faktor und können sich
dann als Superintelligenz neu manifestieren.
Mh. Ähm.
Du sagst grade die Terraner und ähnliche Vögel.
Also ist das auch so, dass im Perirodan-Universum alles so humanoid und ähnlich ist?
Ich glaub, auch diese Arkanoiden, die ersten, die sie dort auf dem Mond treffen,
sind auch eher so menschartig.
Und sind dann auch alle anderen Wesen dieses Universums oder Perivorsums auch so alle so ...
Weil das war eigentlich immer so typisch erstes Star Trek und so,
egal auf welchen Planeten die kamen. ja das konnte noch so weit entfernt sein
von Planeten Erde, alle hatten irgendwie zwei Beine und lief durch die Gegend
und hatten im Prinzip auch die gleichen Probleme.
Ja, also warum das bei Star Trek so läuft ist natürlich klar und ein bisschen
läuft es denke ich auch bei Perioden darauf hinaus,
dass es dramaturgisch interessanter ist mit zwar Fremdintelligenten aber dann
doch menschenähnlichen Wesen zu interagieren,
auch als Romanautor kann man das leichter fassen.
Es gibt eine gewisse Präferenz für humanoide Völker, die sind auch alle miteinander
verwandt, das kommt im Laufe der langen Handlungszeit, über 45 Jahre,
2350 Bände, kommen die Hintergründe heraus, dass es da Verwandtschaftszusammenhänge
auf genetischer Ebene gibt,
aber es gibt auch ganz ganz in absolut der Vielfalt an anderen exotischen Lebensformen,
die teilweise auf ganz anderer Biologie und Genetik beruhen.
Pfeilt dir da etwas ein, was plastisch ist? Ja wunderbarerweise zum Beispiel die Chaluter,
die haben sechs Extremitäten, Laufarme und Handlungsarme, stehen auf zwei Säulenbeinen,
haben ein Planhirn und ein Ordinärhirn, dass dass sie auch abkoppeln können.
Sie haben einen Konverter-Magen, mit der es ihnen ermöglicht,
aus jedem Produkt Stein oder sonst was zu Stoff wechseln.
Sie können ihre Haut in quasi,
unüberwindbare Stahlverbund verwandeln. Und was inzwischen natürlich herauskommt,
ist klar, solche Wesen, die denkt man sich nicht nur aus, die wurden natürlich auch geklont.
Also die sind letztlich freigelassene Geschöpfe, die mal als biologische Kampfwaffen
entwickelt worden sind. A. Mhm.
Was man jetzt schon merkt, wenn du das so erzählst und irgendwie aus der Begriffkiste
zauberst, das ist alles sehr anglizismenfrei.
Also die ganze Perirodan-Welt, wenn man jetzt mal diesen Namen,
den man schon fast gerne lieber englisch aussprechen möchte als deutsch,
wenn man den mal herausnimmt, gibt es eigentlich fast kaum...
Irgendwelche typischen englischen science fiction Begriffe. Zieht sich das wirklich
komplett durch die ganze Serie so durch?
Ich glaube das liegt an dem Kontext von Autoren und Leserschaft,
die noch sehr stark aus der deutschsprachigen Literatur und Sprache geschöpft
haben und Und auch das Wort Science-Fiction,
ist erst in der Nachkriegszeit als Genre langsam,
in das Bewusstsein geraten.
Bis in die 80er Jahre hinein wurde die Perry-Rodan-Serie auch vom Verlag als,
die Weltraum-Serie bezeichnet.
Wichtig war eben, dass man sehr viele Leser aus allen Bevölkerungsschichten,
die auch gerade des Englischen nicht, zur damaligen Zeit, Anfang der 60er Jahre
des Englischen, gar nicht mächtig waren,
sie nicht verwirrt, sondern ihnen die Begriffe an Hand gab, mit denen sie was anfangen konnten.
TROZINSKI Ja, aber daraus hat sich natürlich ein sehr buntes, ja,
so ein Panoptikum von Fachbegriffen ergeben, die für sich genommen schon mal
ganz… BRODER Ja, aber das ist eine ganz interessante Sache, die als Wert erst
jetzt in den letzten Jahren wohl überhaupt gesehen worden ist.
Also es gibt nämlich Wortschöpfung aus den 80er und 90er Jahren,
die durchaus dann Anglizismen verwenden, weil sie einfach wiederum dem Lese-
und dem Bildungskontext der Leserschaft entsprochen haben.
Diese Autoren, also es gibt ja ganz viele, aber es gab mal einen ersten.
Nils gab ein Team, ein Duo von Zweien und die waren jeder für sich in der kleinen
deutschen Science Fiction Gemeinde schon sehr erfolgreich und das war so wie
so ein Supergroup Prinzip,
dass also zwei erfolgreiche Autoren da zusammen gekommen waren und auf Initiative
des Möwig Verlags, damals in München ansässig,
beauftragt worden waren eine Heftroman Serie.
Eine wöchentliche zu konzipieren.
Und damals hatte der Verlag so die Idee, na wir gucken mal, dass wir das über
20 Hefte aufrechterhalten.
In den Künstlerträumen der Autoren.
Dachten die 50 werden es wohl werden und dieser ganz große brückenschlag zu
dem verlassenen planeten und die erloschene sonne das ist also so die. Das war so die ganz.
Also es ist die vision der geschichte aber es war nicht unbedingt die vision des verlags.
Auch nicht mal der macher sondern das war so damit man weiß immer gehen westen aber.
Wie weit man da kommt, ist nochmal eine ganz andere Geschichte.
Dazu möchte ich noch eine schöne Anekdote erzählen, weil die Amerikanisierung war doch so stark,
dass die Serie mit dem Image, dass sie unter Umständen aus Amerika importiert
sein könnte und sich daraus auch so eine kulturelle Überlegenheit der damaligen Zeit manifestiert.
Die ist auch dadurch noch mal gekennzeichnet worden, dass die Autoren sich oft
amerikanische oder englische Pseudonyme zugelegt haben.
Die Geschichte dahinter ist, dass Walter Ernsting, einer der Gründerväter von
Periodon, seinen ersten science fiction Roman unter einem Pseudonym eingereicht
hat, übersetzt von Walter Ernsting.
Er hat dann einen Namen erfunden, Clark Dalton, und hat gesagt, ja,
das habe ich in Science Fiction Illustrated oder Science Fiction, hast du nicht gesehen,
in Amerika gelesen und habe den Autor gefragt, ob ich das übersetzen könnte
und er hat ja gesagt und ich bin auch sein Manager und hat dann entsprechend
seinen ersten Roman unter Pseudonym veröffentlicht.
Und diese Tradition ist so ein bisschen in Perry Roden noch spürbar gewesen bis in die,
70er, 80er Jahre, wenn heute Pseudonyme gewählt werden, die manchmal ja ganz
sinnvoll sind für Autoren, dann sind es aber heute nicht mehr englische Pseudonyme.
Du hast vorhin so schön nochmal betont, der Heftroman, es gibt dann auch noch
den Perirodenzyklus, wie verhält sich das dazu?
Der Zyklus sind viele Heftromane in einem Handlungsbogen zusammengefasst und
darüber hinaus gibt es noch die Großzyklen, das sind dann eben mehrere Unterzyklen
in einem großen Großzyklus.
So der normale Zyklus umfasst 50 bis 100 Hefte und die Großzyklen bis zu 400,
aber dann immer unterteilt in 50er oder 100er Schritten und das ist auch eine klare,
fassbare Größe, 50 Hefte entsprechend praktisch einem Jahr und lässt sich dann
entsprechend auch ganz gut so für die Leser und auch für die Autoren so im Kopf behalten.
Also jetzt ist man schon bei 2.300.
Und 42 glaube ich also schon echt eine menge und das geht auch munter weiter
also es gibt da keinerlei,
ja interessant ist eigentlich dass der heft roman als solches als gattung eigentlich
ein absterbendes genre ist das ist aber dem,
Perry Rodan Heftroman relativ gut geht,
was einfach an guter Arbeit, guten Heften und inzwischen auch einem sehr hohen
Wissensstand um die Serie selber und also einen gewissen selbstreferentiellen
Status, der am Anfang nicht da war,
also man guckt jetzt auf die 45 Jahre zurück,
praktisch alle handelnden Personen sind aus der eigenen Fanbasis erwachsen.
Sind alle mit Perry Rodan sozialisiert worden und als solche natürlich sehr,
sehr sensibel für alle Veränderungen, aber auch alle Qualitäten,
die nötig sind, um die gewachsene Fanbasis auch weiterhin bei Laune zu halten.
Und so dass eine sehr gute Mischung aus klassischen Elementen,
klassischen Völkern, vertrauten Personen besteht und immer wieder neu hinzugeführten
Handlungselementen, Völkern, Planeten und Storylines kommt.
Wie groß muss man sich diese Fanbasis vorstellen? Weißt du zufällig was für
Auflagen diese Hefte erzielen?
Also ich vermute, Wissen tue ich das nicht, dass das so normale Periodenheft
wohl so um etwas über die 100.000 im Durchschnitt an Auflage hat.
100.000?
Ja ich vermute das schwankt mal mehr.
Jede Woche?
Jede Woche.
Also jede Woche werden 100.000 Hefte.
Oder mehr. Oder mehr. Oder wenn die ein schlechtes Heft und einen schlechten
Titel und vor allen Dingen die Titelbilder machen sogar was aus.
Also es gibt einen Großteil wohl Impulskäufer.
Macht wahrscheinlich so ein Drittel aus, das sind so die derzeit oder Wehrpflichtige,
der halt sich am Bahnhofs Kiosk irgendwie langweilt und dann greift das durch
so ein Heft und das ist dann auch in 70 Minuten durch und dann wird das dann
oft auch weggeschmissen, das ist nach wie vor ein gängiges Muster.
Die Sammler und Fans als solche sind wohl eine qualifizierte Minderheit.
Kann ich nicht sagen, wie viel das immer an diesem jeweiligen Bereich ausmacht.
Und ja, ich glaube, dass zumindest in der alten Bundesrepublik die männliche Bevölkerung unter 40,
dass praktisch jeder mal ein, äh über 40, bei den alten Bundesländern mal ein
Perlrodenheft gelesen hat.
Ah, okay. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte jetzt auch noch eins lesen müssen,
aber die Kategorie falle ich noch nicht so ganz.
Und dann gibt's ja sicherlich auch so Treffen, so Cons oder so.
Ich meine, wenn das erstmal so ein Kult ist, dann gibt's ja meistens auch Meetings.
Warst du da mal bei einem? A.
Jaja, das ist auch gerade in der Zeit vor dem Internet waren natürlich Real-Life-Begegnungen,
absolut,
wichtig, um sich selbst zu vergewissern, dass man in seiner normalen Umwelt,
wo man dann oft ja ein bisschen mit seiner Leidenschaft etwas merkwürdig beäugt,
wird, dass man sich ein, zweimal im Jahr mit anderen Menschen,
die genauso drauf sind, trifft.
Und das galt für die Science-Fiction in Deutschland im Allgemeinen und gilt
auch weltweit für die Science-Fiction im Allgemeinen, als auch dann spezifisch,
für eine Serie wie Peril Rodan.
Ich muss mal dazu sagen, dass zum Beispiel Periodon mich praktisch versaut hat
für alle andere literarische Science-Fiction.
Weil in Periodon, das ist so ein mächtiges Universum, dass alle Bedürfnisse,
die ich in dem Bereich Weltraum, Galaxien, kosmische Rätsel so habe,
dort alles abgedeckt wird.
Das heißt, du bist für Star Trek und Star Wars nicht mehr empfänglich?
Nee, ich meine literarisch. Also, da es die regelmäßige Periode an Fernsehserien
nicht gibt und auch die Verfilmung davon nicht gibt im Hollywood-Maßstab, ist das nicht der Fall.
Aber so im literarischen Bereich ist es dann oft so, dass ich beim Lesen gewisse
Defizite habe. Da fehlt mir die Vertrautheit.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wer ist das jetzt? Und wenn die mit dem Raumschiff umherfliegen,
dann muss ich genau wissen, ist das ein Linearantrieb?
Haben die einen Kalupschen Kompensationskonverter oder haben sie einen Warrington
in Ultrakompbauweise an Bord? Wie oft müssen sie das wechseln?
Oder ist es noch ein antiquiertes Transitionstriebwerk?
Die normale Science Fiction, zumindest die literarische, gibt mir diese Informationen
nicht. Da steht dann irgendwie, sie haben den großen Raumsprung gemacht und
das war's und dann geht's dann in die Handlung.
Die Technik ist so ein wunderbarer, wie so eine Baseline, die ständig so im
Untergrund pulst und für ganz ganz viele Periodenleser auch wichtig ist.
Es gibt andere für die ist das nicht so wichtig, insbesondere auch viele Autoren,
die aus anderen Bereichen kommen, die das sich mühsam wie so Vokabeln angelernt haben.
Aber der eine Gründungsvater, Karl Herbert Scheer, der hat ganz minutiös seine
Techno-Fantasien da hineingeschrieben und auch ganz, ganz minutiös.
Darauf geachtet, dass die Technik da funktioniert hat.
Und jeder Autor musste also so ein kleines Technologiestudium in Perirodan-Technologie,
absolvieren, bevor er schreiben durfte.
Und es gibt auch mal einen Autor, der ist aus dem Team rausgeflogen,
weil er es gewagt hatte, in einem Roman eine Technikpanne zu beschreiben an
einem terranischen Raumschiff.
Das darf doch nicht sein.
Begründung war, ein terranisches Raumschiff hat keine Technikpannen.
Das erzählt bei der NASA.
Also Technik spielt eine große Rolle. Du bist ja an einem Punkt auch ganz konkret
mit beschäftigt gewesen, weil in den Heften, also nicht in allen Heften, aber wohl in...
Einigen, vielen, wie soll man das ausdrücken? Jeden vierten.
In jedem vierten gibt es dann sogenannte Risszeichnungen.
Das ist ja auch ein Genre, was quasi aus dem Perirhodan-Kulturuniversum,
heraus entstanden ist. Das sind grob gesagt so 3D-artige Zeichnungen eben dieser
Primärraumschiffe oder sonstigen Gerätschaften,
die in so einem Aufriss halt als hätte man aus einem Apfel was herausgebissen,
so dass man eben diese Innereien sehen kann.
Kannst du mal zu dieser Kultur beschreiben, wie das entstanden ist?
Für mich ist die sogar die wichtigere gewesen, um überhaupt der Faszination
des Periodenuniversums zu erliegen.
Denn das ist, ein Bild sagt dann doch eben mehr als 1.000 Worte.
Und diese Risszeichnungen, die die Raumschiffe und Gerätschaften der Helden
dargestellt haben, haben mich sehr fasziniert.
Und die wirkten wirklich wie eine Blaupause aus der Zukunft.
Man muss dazu verstehen, diese Zeichnungen wurden zur damaligen Zeit von professionellen
Illustratoren gemacht,
die ansonsten für Modelleisenbahnhersteller gearbeitet haben oder sich als Architekten
verdingt haben. Die waren zur damaligen Zeit state-of-the-art der technischen,
Illustrationen,
in
anderen,
Medien auch. Das heißt, eine Perirodanrisszeichnung zu einem Raumschiff oder
einem Raumgleiter sah nicht anders aus,
als in der Automotor und Sport eine Durchsicht oder Röntgenzeichnung von einem
VW Käfer oder von einem anderen.
Das war ja damals auch sehr populär.
Das war ein ganz populäres Medium, dass man den Hobby Magazin der Technik gesehen
hat und das Verblüffende war halt eben dieses 1 zu 1 Verhältnis zwischen der
realen Technik und der Fantasietechnik im Periodenuniversum,
die so dargestellt worden ist. Und das hatte...
Für mich eine solche Attraktion und Überzeugungskraft, dass das nochmal den
ganzen Glaubwürdigkeits- und Faszinationscharakter so potenziert hat.
Und wie erstellt man solche Risszeichnungen? Also welche Produktionsmethoden
hast du da am Anfang gewählt? Wann hast du damit angefangen?
Schon ganz ganz früh, direkt quasi mit den ersten Heften, die ich gelesen habe,
da waren dann auch schon diese Zeichnungen drin und ich kannte die Zeichnungen
auch vor den Heftromanen schon als so kleine Miniposter.
Und war das jetzt 80er?
Nee, nee, das war Mitte der 70er Jahre und ich kannte sie aber schon von Anfang
der 70er Jahre als ganz kleines Kind sogar schon aus dem Peri Rodan Comics Magazin.
Das ist nochmal so ein Spin-Off gewesen, der für einige Jahre sehr erfolgreich
war und dort waren die schon in den Heften mal, also in den Heftromanen veröffentlichten,
Zeichnungen auch als Zugabe mit drin.
Und da versucht man mit allen Mitteln, erst mit Bleistift natürlich und ohne
Lineal und wundert sich dann erstmal, dass es alles so krakelig aussieht.
Dann sagt man sich, okay, man nimmt vielleicht auch Lineale,
dann wundert man sich, dass man aber die Kurven nicht so schön hinbekommt.
Dann lernt man auf einmal, es gibt ja Kurvenlineale, was irgendwie so ein bisschen absurd klingt.
Und dann lernt man auch wiederum, dass man bei Beleihstiftzeichnungen ja gar
nicht reprofähig sind, also muss man da andere Hilfsmittel einsetzen.
Ja und so kommt man immer von Schritt zu Schritt und zu einem...
Zu einem Standardverfahren, das für die analoge Verfertigung von Risszeichnungen bis etwa,
bis Anfang der 90er Jahre so aussah, dass man eine Bleistiftvorzeichnung gemacht hat,
die mehr oder minder schon sehr akkurat war, wo man aber natürlich Hilfslinien
und Konstruktionslinien drin hatte und dass man ab einem gewissen Fertigungsgrad
gesagt hat, so die Zeichnung ist jetzt fertig,
dann ein Transparentpapier über die Zeichnung geklebt hat und dann nochmal alles
mit Tuschelfiltern von Rotring oder anderen Firmen,
teilweise mit ganz irrsinnigen Kapillardurchmesser der Nadeln,
also der Minen bis 0,13 Millimeter.
Was zu einer hohen Präzision geführt hat, aber gerade die 0.13 Millimeter Rapidographen,
waren sehr empfindlich.
Also Rapidograph klingt ja auch schon wie ein Begriff aus dem Perirodern.
Richtig, aber eigentlich vorher war der Isograph und dann kam der Rapidograph.
Das war dann glaube ich eine nächste Evolutionsstufe.
Und wie viele Risszeichnungen hast du so produziert über die Zeit?
Ich vermute, so ein Dutzend in der Peripedia wird das wahrscheinlich alles ganz genau stehen.
A, genau, da können wir ja auch gleich mal drauf verweisen, jetzt treten wir
ja auch in die moderne Zeit ein und du hast ja auch gesagt, so damals,
als alles noch ohne Internet war, musste man sich immer treffen,
jetzt trifft man sich natürlich auch online. Es gibt einen Perirodan-Online-Club, PROC,
die auch eine Wikipedia-artige,
Artikelsammlung,
aufgesetzt,
haben,
nämlich die Peripedia, wo sich alles Mögliche zum Perirodan-Universum findet.
Ich bin hier schon wieder mit größtem Staunen am Blättern und da bekommt man
überhaupt erstmal einen Eindruck, wie komplex diese Perirodan-Welt ist.
Ja, über 200.000 Manuskriptseiten.
Vermutlich.
Die jetzt, was meinst du jetzt, als Grundlage des, der… Das ist gewissermaßen
der kanonisierte Teil der Texte. Jetzt in der Peripedia?
Nicht in der Peripedia, aber diese
Peripedia basiert ja auf etwa 200.000 kanonisierten Manuskriptseiten,
die die Gesamtheft-Roman-Serie… Was meinst du jetzt mit kanonisierte… Ja,
es gibt ja nun sehr viele Fan-Literatur von Amateuren,
die auch mal einen Periode an Erzählungen schreiben wollen, um mal Schriftsteller,
zu werden und es an den Verlag schreiben.
Und es gibt so offizieuse Geschichten, dass vielleicht ein auch richtiger Periodenautor
eine kleine Kurzgeschichte für ein Fan-Scene wiederum geschrieben hat.
Davon weiß aber der Lektor eigentlich nur so vom Hörensagen und das wird nicht
in die offizielle Kontinuität des Universums eingeführt.
Also man muss halt sagen, alles was dort in irgendeiner Form geschehen ist, ist nach wie vor gültig.
Mhm. Okay, zurück zur Peripedia, können wir mal kurz hier schauen, 7.270 Artikel.
Was mich ein bisschen umgehauen hat, ist allein schon mal hier die Liste aller
Kategorien, die also auch extrem gut organisiert ist.
Und so Metakategorien wie Kosmologie allein umfassen schon mal 148 Artikel.
Und im Bereich Phänomene 61 Artikel, wo also dann auch hier wahrscheinlich deine
Superintelligenz mit dabei ist.
Nein, tatsächlich gilt das nicht als Phänomen. Okay, ich hab mich getäuscht.
Vielleicht ist es in der Kosmologie unter Zwiebelschalenmodell drin.
TROZINSKI Ja, Zwiebelschalenmodell ist hier drin, richtig.
BRODER Das ist also wirklich ein wichtiger und guter Einstieg,
um sich in die Perirhodan-Kosmologie hinein zu bringen. TROZINSKI Das Zwiebelschalenmodell?
BRODER Ja, das ist ein ganz wichtiger.
TROZINSKI Aber was noch sehr viel beeindruckender ist, ist die Liste der Organisationen,
die liegt nämlich mal locker bei 328 verschiedenen.
Ja, aber wenn man überlegt, dass allein die von den Terranern wirklich dargestellte
Handlungszeitraum, ich glaube inzwischen über 3000 Jahre umfasst,
dann gibt es da natürlich Organisationen, die kommen und gehen.
Die kommen und gehen.
Geheimdienste werden gegründet, Imperien sterben ab, neue Geheimdienste werden
wieder gegründet für neue Nachfolgestaaten,
Imperium Dabrifa, Kasualscher Bund, Liga Freier Taraner, Solaris Imperium.
Was sind denn die wichtigsten Organisationen, die man so zwangsläufig kennenlernt?
Also ich meine, ist es so, dass die jetzt alle permanent wechseln oder gibt
es nicht so ein paar Hauptthemen, die fast in jedem Heften irgendeiner Form Anklang finden?
Also jetzt Terraner werden sicherlich, ist sicherlich ein Thema, was immer kommt.
Ja, es kann dir passieren als Neuleser, dass du erstmal Periroh dann liest und
über acht Bände hinweg erstens mal Periroh dann nie zu Gesicht bekommst.
Und auch nie einen Terraner oder wenn dann nur so einen Terraner,
der ganz ganz weit in fremden Galaxien unterwegs ist und eigentlich nicht weiß,
wie er wieder zurückkommt.
Und ähm... Die Handlungs...
Elemente sind eigentlich, vielleicht sollte ich da nochmal sagen,
weil das mit die Faszination ausmacht.
Es geht nicht so um das primäre Lesevergnügen.
Da würde ich mal sagen, das ist dem Heft-Roman-Genre angepasst,
mittelmäßig.
Es
gibt, würde ich mal sagen, auf zehn Hefte kommen drei wirklich ganz schlechte,
Drei, die man so mit gutem Gewissen gerade noch so erträglich findet,
dann kommen, jetzt sind wir bei sechs, kommen vielleicht drei gute und ein wirkliches
Heft, das man auch einem Freund empfehlen möchte.
Und aber jeder einzelne Roman bietet Puzzlesteine, Informationsspurenelemente,
die einem zu dem ganz großen Zyklus Meta-Handlungssträngen.
Führen. Und man ist dann oft sogar ein bisschen weiter als die aktuellen Protagonisten
auf der Handlungsebene,
weil man ja vorher in einer anderen Handlungsebene, 30 Millionen Lichtjahre
entfernt, auf einen ähnlichen komischen Pilzdom gestoßen ist,
der aber für die Protagonisten auf der aktuellen Handlungsebene ganz neu ist.
Und als Leser weiß ich schon, was so ein Pilzdom alles tut und was man damit machen kann.
Und dann kommt also dieser Suspense-Charakter mit rein und es gibt natürlich
auch falsche Fährten und inzwischen werden auch diese ganzen Stränge sehr professionell,
also die Textverarbeitung, der E-Mail-Verkehr zwischen den Autoren hilft dabei,
sehr,
professionell,
miteinander verknüpft. und die Qualität auf dieser Ebene, nämlich die Leser
über Monate hinweg mit gezielt,
mit Injektionen von interessanten Handlungselementen zu versorgen,
dass man dann anfängt, oh, wie könnte es jetzt weitergehen?
Also die eigentliche Handlung, das eigentliche Lesevergnügen fängt an,
wenn man den Roman ausgelesen hat und sich überlegt, wie könnte es jetzt weitergehen?
Also das Cliffhanger-Prinzip.
Also die Peripetia könnt ihr ja dann tendenziell auch wirklich als äh...
Vernetzung zentrale fungieren also wenn man sich anschaut was die wikipedia
heute schon für eine deutungsmacht hat und auch so sagen wir mal grundlegende
orientierung für recherche bietet ist das ja sicherlich in so einem universum auch durchaus so.
Ja ich denke dass die peripedia vom vom proc inzwischen auch diese diesen kristallisationskern hat.
Ich weiß aber, es gibt vom Verlag aus ein zentrales Register aller Items und
Assets aus dem Periroden-Universum und das ist wohl noch ein bisschen umfangreicher.
Da wird es mal interessant sein, wie beide Systeme miteinander korrelieren und
ob gewissermaßen das offizielle redaktionelle Datenbanksystem nicht von der
Peripedia übertroffen wird.
Und das kann ich momentan noch nicht entscheiden.
Ich wollte noch mal kurz auf die
Technik zurückkommen. Raumschiffe spielen natürlich eine große Bedeutung.
Also, das haben wir schon bei den Risszeichnungen gemerkt.
Es hilft, die Protagonisten von einem Handlungsort zum anderen zu bringen.
Also gibt's ja auch alle möglichen Modelle, wie man das Universum so durchschreitet.
Ja.
Das sind ja immer sehr, also eigentlich fast allen Science Fiction,
Sei es der Anhalter mit seiner Bistromatik oder ...
Unwahrscheinlichkeits-Drive.
Der Unwahrscheinlichkeits-Drive vor allem natürlich. Und hier bei Star Trek
natürlich auch die ganzen Warpstufen und so weiter.
Ich steck da gar nicht selber so tief drin. Gibt's da herausragende Grundannahmen,
wie das Universum aufgebaut ist und wie man diese unendlichen Weiten durchschreiten kann? Ja.
In Perirodern, die jetzt erwähnenswert wären?
Ich möchte dazu noch mal sagen, die Technologie ist in den ersten 40 Jahren
des Periodenuniversums so gewuchert und so,
ultimativ geworden, dass es dramaturgische Handlungszusammenhänge sehr erschwert hat.
Das heißt, die Galaxis war also die Milchstraße, die man manchmal so am Himmel
noch sehen kann, die hatte nur noch die Funktion, die bei uns der Globus hatte.
Das heißt, was in den Anfangszeiten noch eine zeitaufwendige Expedition in unerforschten
Weiten war, konnte man inzwischen mit so einem Jet-Set-Sprung,
innerhalb,
von wenigen Stunden erledigen. Und deswegen gab es vor einiger Zeit einen universumsweiten Degrader.
Ein Anglizismus.
Oha! Alarmglocken.
Die höchsten uns bekannten Mächte des Universums haben beschlossen,
das Leben nimmt überhand.
Es ist zu schnell von A nach B unterwegs und es hilft uns nicht.
Man muss sich das so vorstellen wie...
Eine Entzerrung des Universums sozusagen.
Ja und zwar wurde der hyperphysikalische Widerstand erhöht mit dem Widerstandsproblematik,
dass alles auf einmal sehr sehr viel langsamer ging.
Dass Energien schneller ausgelaugt waren, also dass die Energiesysteme schneller
ausgelaugt waren und bestimmte Hyperkristalle, die dafür gesorgt haben,
dass Transformationsprozesse stattfinden konnten, die
mussten ausgetauscht werden und durch Niederwertige ersetzt werden und die gesamte
Technologie ist innerhalb eines einzigen Tages praktisch dann auf das Niveau
der Anfangsromane zurückgeschnellt.
Zum Schluss war ein 60 Millionen facher Überlichtfaktor bei einem normalen Raumschiffsflug
gang und gäbe und mit den jetzigen Systemen ist glaube ich eine theoretische
Geschwindigkeit noch von 15 oder 20 Millionenfach wohl möglich,
aber in der Praxis total irrsinnig.
Und deswegen scheint jetzt so die Reisegeschwindigkeit nur noch anderthalb Millionenfach
zu sein. Sprich, wenn man ...
Da müsste man ein Jahr lang unterwegs sein, um die nächste Nachbargalaxis zu erreichen.
Und damit wird das alles wieder interessanter.
Also, das heißt, eine andere Galaxis zu reisen, ist wirklich ein Abenteuer und
nicht mal so, ach, haben wir 72 Stunden Zeit, dann lass uns mal nach Andromeda fliegen.
Das wurde irgendwann zu inflationär und hat auch die Leser nicht mehr beeindruckt.
Und schafft dann auch die Konflikte wieder ein bisschen zu regionalisieren. Genau.
Und in eigenen Bereiche zu stemmen. Und dieser Degrader, wie muss man sich, auf welcher Ebene?
Ich meine, es gibt ja mit diesem Zwiebelschalenmodell, gibt es ja schon so eine,
ja im Prinzip so eine Abstufung von unbelebter Materie bis hin zu den absoluten Überwesen.
Es gibt einen sogenannten moralischen Code. Mir gefällt die ganze Idee nicht so gut.
Also ich will es mal als Metapher nur verstehen, dass das Universum durchzogen
ist von einer Art kosmischen DNA.
Diese DNA regelt den Energiezufuhr auf hyperphysikalischer Ebene zwischen den
einzelnen im Multiversum eingebetteten einzelnen Universen und bestimmte sogenannte,
wie heißen sie denn jetzt gerade,
Kosmonokloidite heißen die
genau wie, also das ist vollkommen eins zu eins von der DNA übernommen,
die regeln halt gewissermaßen die Flexibilität und Spannkraft innerhalb bestimmter
Regionen des Universums und die jetzige Informationen lauten halt,
dass diese auf Universumsweiter Ebene diese Kosmonukleotide eben diesen Widerstand erhöht haben.
A. Für mich aber gerade nicht in der Peripedia die Kosmonukleotide.
Guck mal unter Dorypha, das ist so das bekannteste.
Wie schreibt sich das? B.
Dorypha, wie man es spricht mit F. Dorypha? B.
DORIFER, D O R I F E R und GROSS.
Ahh natürlich, ja sprich weiter.
Und die COSMONUKLEITE, da waren wir, ah ja genau, ich hab nach Plural gesucht.
Okay, DORIFER, alles klar.
Ja.
Das ist so ausführlich hier, unfassbar.
Wobei man dazu sagen muss, dass es..
Also was macht jetzt diese DNA? Die ist sozusagen dann die Grundlage alles über
natürlichen Wesens in..
Es ist halt ein Regelungssystem, das dort wohl behauptet wird im perirodnern
Universum, unser Universum zu regeln.
Es gibt aber auch Stimmen, die einfach sagen, dass da Leute sich hinstellen, die halt genau wissen,
wann ein kröstenloses Nukleotid eben auf oder zu macht und wie den dummen Eingeborenen
halt erklären, guckt mal da ist die Sonnenfinsternis und besonders die sagen
nicht, wenn ihr jetzt nicht macht, was ich will,
dann passt mal auf, was jetzt am Himmel passiert und dann kommt die Sonnenfinsternis
und alle werfen sich in den Boden und danach wissen sie, das ist der Gott,
weil der hat es nämlich geschafft, dass die Sonne wieder scheint.
Das wäre gewissermaßen der dramaturgische Trick, den unter Umständen mal als
Notaussagen benutzt werden könnte, um diesem manchmal schon etwas verstiegenen
äh, Universumsmodell auszuweichen.
Es ist auch gar nicht klar, ob dieser Degrader jetzt kosmosweit ist.
Er ist halt nur insoweit kosmosweit, wie man den Kosmos halt beobachten kann
und äh, an bestimmten Stellen ist.
Das ist momentan noch nicht entschieden.
Okay, also die Superintelligenzen scheinen mir auch noch nicht die höchste Form
zu sein. Da gibt es auch noch interessanterweise die Kosmokraten und die Chaotarchen.
Ja, auch dieses manichärische Weltbild, dass es da sowas wie gute oder böse
Kräfte gibt, ist natürlich ein bisschen komisch.
Sie spielen jetzt innerhalb des Autorenteams auch ein bisschen damit,
dass die Guten gar nicht so gut sind und vielleicht sind die Chaotarchen auch gar nicht so schlecht.
Wobei man das jetzt nicht so sagen kann, im Moment in der aktuellen Handlung
überfallen nämlich die Kräfte des Chaos mit großer Macht gerade die gesamte
Milchstraße und haben sie gewissermaßen unter ihre Knute genommen.
Ist den Chaos hier generell etwas Negatives? die.
Die Chaos Kolonne so heißt dieser Trupp von vielen Milliarden von Wesen die
da die Milchstraße gerade überrunnen hat scheint mir ein sehr recht geordneter Haufen zu sein.
Interessanterweise gibt es ja auch einen Periroden nämlich ist noch gar nicht
so lange her 2300 muss gerade mal ein Jahr her sein, heißt vorboten des Chaos.
Ein exzellenter Roman, den ich einfach nur super empfehlen kann,
weil es sehr actionlastig und es geht richtig zur Sache.
Und man ist sofort in einer absolut spannenden Handlung drin. Und ...
Gibt's auch gelesen als Hörspiel?
Ja, ich glaube, in so einer Marketingbundle mit Computerbildspielen oder so was.
Also lässt sich auch im Internet finden, sozusagen.
Als Einstieg kann ich's wirklich empfehlen, weil auch ein ganz neuer Handlungsstrang
dort eröffnet worden ist, der mit wenig Voraussetzungen funktioniert.
A. Ja, das Universum von Perirodan.
Gibt's denn noch etwas Abschließendes zu bemerken, was wir jetzt vielleicht
noch nicht touchiert haben?
Ich meine, durch das ganze Periversum werden wir uns hier ohnehin nicht diskutieren können.
Nee, ich finde noch mal wichtig, dass die Leserschaft sich gewissermaßen des
Projekts angenommen hat, dass wichtige Autoren,
Redaktionsmitarbeiter, alle ehemalige und natürlich nach wie vor Fans sind und
dass diese Verbindung zwischen der Fanbasis und den Machern aus meiner Sicht
ausgezeichnet funktioniert.
Und wie so ein basisdemokratisches Mittel funktioniert und auch den wirtschaftlichen
Erfolg der Serie natürlich unterstützt,
weil wenn Dinge in eine falsche Richtung abdriften,
kommt entsprechendes Feedback sehr schnell und sehr fundiert und man kann das auch lesen.
Also die Macher können das sehr schnell lesen, und zwar oft innerhalb von 10,
12 Bänden und sogar gewissermaßen...
Noch mal einen anderen Weg einschlagen, wenn sie das Gefühl haben,
dass sie einen Fehler gemacht haben.
Trotzdem ist es schwierig, so ein Kollektiv von vielleicht zehn,
zwölf Mitarbeitern mit jeweils eigenständigen, kreativen Ideen so zu verzahnen,
dass denen die Arbeit Spaß macht, jeder seine Idee reinbringt und auch die Qualität gut ist.
Also ich finde die Qualitätsschwankungen, die manchmal da sind.
Klaus Frick, der Chefredakteur von Perioden, wenn er dann auf Kritik antworten
muss, sagt eben manchmal, meine Alternative ist nicht ein gutes oder ein schlechtes
Heft, sondern ein Heft oder kein Heft zu veröffentlichen.
Aber es muss eigentlich jede woche eins raus muss jede woche eins ganz schöner
stress ja sind die denn alle also ich meine ja ach nochmal zum der arbeitsprozess
ist so es gibt expose autoren die nur outlines festlegen.
Und die anknüpfungspunkte an die vor und die folgeromane darlegen und innerhalb
dieses handlungsgerüst hat dann der jeweilige autor.
Einen mehr oder weniger großen oder auch von ihm, dem Autor zu schaffenden Freiraum,
in dem er sich austoben kann oder auch manchmal nicht tut.
Und dann ergibt sich das alles. Gibt es denn eigentlich auch,
also gab es oder gibt es Pläne, das Perironen-Universum mal auf andere Medien,
in irgendeiner Form zu expandieren?
Ja, das gibt es in unterschiedlichster Form momentan wohl recht erfolgreich
mit Hörspiel-Adaptionen,
auch ganz zeitnah zu den aktuellen Heften und auch das Genre des Lese-Hörbuchs,
mit.
Den Heft-Romanen. Es gibt ältere Texte zum Beispiel als Download PDF Dokumente
in recht günstiger, ich glaube 10 Cent pro alten Heft kann man sich direkt vom Verlag runterladen.
Es gibt immer mal wieder Versuche zum Beispiel in die Verfilmung hinein zu gehen.
Es gibt ja einen inzwischen mit Kultstatus behafteten Periodenfilm aus dem Jahre 65 glaube ich,
in Italien mit dem Cinecitta Prinzip als sehr trashigen, aber zur damaligen
Zeit durchaus auch ernstzunehmende,
wirtschaftlich ernstzunehmende Produktion geplanten Film, der sehr viel Zeitcolorit
inzwischen mit sich bringt, aber wenig Perirodan.
Aber diese Urgeschichte doch so dargestellt hat, dass man durchaus auch die
Folgeromane, also diese Exposition hat man schon gesehen und man kann dann was damit anfangen.
Comics gab es Anfang der 70er Jahre, gibt es jetzt momentan von der Krokodil-Farm,
in Hamburg ein Kollektiv, das versucht der direkten Kontinuität der damals eingestellten,
sogenannten Pop-Art, psychedelischen Comics-Kultur,
das,
fortzuführen,
und,
mit erstaunlichen Erfolg. Sie haben also wirklich den Stil,
der,
Zeit damals getroffen.
Welcher zeit war das?
Das war anfang der 70er jahre, so ein superhelden klassischen marvel stil mit
ganz explodierenden pop art,
hippie farben, also der weltraum war nicht mehr schwarz, sondern das war so
ein einziges, ein clsd trip.
Ja, damals war ja auch noch, ich meine, man muss ja immer klar machen,
1961 ging Perry Roden mit einer Mondlandung los, die dann real erst viele Jahre
später stattgefunden hat.
Es war sicherlich absehbar, dass alle da hin wollten.
Es war das Kennedy Statement, Kennedy hatte das im Mai 1961 propagiert und die
Macher haben einfach dieses Statement innerhalb von zehn Jahren einfach eins
zu eins übertragen und damit das, Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen!
Die perioden heft roman serie fängt also im jahre 1971 19 juni 1971 an.
Wobei in den usa sozusagen tatsächlich noch zuvor kam genau die realität kam
ihnen zuvor und es war damals im jahre 61 natürlich einen zukunfts roman etwas
aus dem jahr 71 zu schreiben dadurch kommt auch die etwas absurde Situation, dass natürlich,
wenn heute die alten Hefte produziert werden, sie natürlich schon in der Vergangenheit liegen.
Also die ersten 50 Hefte sind alle jetzt erkennbar in einem Paralleluniversum
angesiedelt, weil das bei uns nicht geschehen ist.
Was ich mich auch frage, das ist ja wirklich eine zutiefst deutsche Kulturgeschichte, das Perirodan.
Wie schätzt du denn da die Chancen ein, dass das auch nochmal sich globalisiert?
Alles was aus den USA kommt, das findet irgendwie überall Widerhall.
Perirodan in dem Sinne ist nicht so bekannt. Also ich denke mal über die Grenzen
von Deutschland hinaus.
Es wird auch in anderen Ländern produziert. Ich weiß nicht wo überall Perirodenhefte
übersetzt und erschienen sind.
Es sind Nischenprodukte in anderen Science-Fiction-Märkten und den dortigen,
Kennern bewusst und ich glaube auch, dass
jeder, der sich weltweit als Science-Fiction-Fan und Kenner bezeichnet,
dieses Phänomen,
Perioden,
kennt.
Weil,
es
die,
langdauerndste,
und,
langlaufendste,
Serie,
ist, mit der unvorstellbaren,
großen,
Menge,
an
kontinuierlichen,
Texten,
ist.
Eine Globalisierung halte ich für nicht so wahrscheinlich, weil,
Die Globalisierung von solchen Phänomenen läuft über audiovisuelle Medien und
dafür halte ich Periodon nicht mehr so geeignet, einfach weil das Universum so komplex ist.
Und auch bestimmte Dinge für den amerikanischen Markt nicht so leicht zu erläutern sind.
Also der erste Roman endet damit, dass Peri Rodan seine Schulterklappen von
der US Space Force abreißt und damit Fahnenflucht begeht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das für ein amerikanisches Publikum in irgendeiner Form aufbereiten kann.
A, vielleicht nicht für ein amerikanisches Publikum, aber ich glaube für den
Rest der Welt wäre das ein durchaus aktuelles Thema. A.
B. Ja, mir fällt aber außer der FIFA-WM eigentlich kein Produkt ein,
das so globalisiert und erfolgreich ist und den amerikanischen Markt dabei ignorieren kann.
Und die Formel 1 ist auch noch ähnlich dran, ich glaube Perry Rodan wird das nicht schaffen.
Vielleicht ist das ja auch ein Trend der Zeit. Aber gibt es denn dann andere
Kulturprodukte oder auch speziell Science-Fiction-Geschichten oder Filme,
wo ein Einfluss von Perry Rodan klar ersichtlich ist?
Ja. Also in der jüngeren Zeit sehe ich es bei Independence Day von Roland Emmerich,
der kommt aus dem schwäbischen und sein Production Designer Oliver Scholl hat
als Risszeichner großartige Zeichnungen im Peril-Rodan-Risszeichner-Team abgeliefert,
ist,
dann mit, hat auch ganz bewusst vom, vom,
sich als Designer verstanden eine Ausbildung gemacht und ist dann als Production
Designer mit Roland Emmerich nach Hollywood gegangen und hat dort nach wie vor
große Erfolge auch für viele andere Filme gearbeitet.
Und bei Independence Day sieht man ein Prinzip, dass der Staatschef auch der Held ist.
Und das ist auch noch mal bei Wolfgang Petersen in Air Force One,
wo der Präsident wirklich aktiv eingreift und Dinge tut und das ist glaube ich
etwas, das liegt in der Tradition von Perry Roland.
Denn der ist gewissermaßen der Staatschef, der lässt sich wählen,
aber er ist auch derjenige, der an vorderster Front sich irgendwie den,
den ins Einsatzkommando setzt und dann den entscheidenden Hack macht.
Der totale Superheld sozusagen.
Und das ist etwas, was, glaube ich, für die Amerikaner aus der Kenntnis ihrer
Kultur eigentlich vollkommen unvorstellbar ist.
Und da mussten halt die Deutschen, die Hollywood erobert haben,
Petersen und Emmerich kommen, die genau diese Sicht,
diese vollkommen naive Sicht dann auch wirklich in ihren Film reingetragen haben
und ich glaube, etwas dabei sogar geschafft haben, was ihnen die Amerikaner
nie haben bringen können.
Also wirklich mal den Chef zu sehen. Und als Bush das dann mit Mission Accomplished
versucht hat, ist es dann ja auch entsprechend in die Hose gegangen,
weil da kann man halt den Hollywood Vorbildern nicht mehr folgen.
Aber das ist, scheint mir auch so ein bisschen, da wollten sie wirklich die
Bilder aus Independence Day gewissermaßen nachholen und das hat nicht geklappt.
A. Es gibt jetzt noch so Begleitpublikationen, sowas wie Atlan,
die auch als Hefte erscheinen.
Was spielt das für eine Rolle?
Der Atlan ist quasi ein freundlicher Antagonist von Perirodan,
der von der Superintelligenz S in eine ähnliche Funktion gebracht worden ist
wie Perirodan, aber zu einer Zeit,
als die Menschen auf Terra noch praktisch in primitiven Verhältnissen gelebt haben.
Die Figur wurde relativ, also nach etwa einem Jahr einfach eingeführt und hat
dann auch so die Vergangenheitsperspektive eröffnet.
Und interessant ist einfach, dass man jetzt zwei Helden, ähnlich wie Winnetou
und Old Shatterhand, hat, die so unterschiedliche Aspekte von Mannsein und von Heldsein verkörpern.
Atlan ist härter, draufgängerischer, mehr der Womanizer.
In der Verfolgung von Zielen logischer und unerbittlicher Perioden ist sogar
als Figur, wird da sogar eher gemieden.
Die Figur Peri Rodan ist mit all den kosmischen Ereignissen und Geschichte,
die eben gewissermaßen als Mensch aufgebürdet wird, für die Autoren sehr schwer zu beschreiben.
Sodass man inzwischen das Phänomen sieht, dass die Seitenprotagonisten,
die mal für ein Heft zum Helden des Tages werden und am Ende des Tages,
wenn alles vorbei ist, Periode an die Hand schütteln dürfen.
Und die schildern dann diesen Menschen, der seit mehreren Jahrtausenden lebt,
unglaubliche Lebenserfahrung hat und eigentlich als normaler Mensch aus Fleisch
und Blut dramaturgisch nicht mehr so richtig handhabbar ist.
TROZINSKI Schwierig mit Übermenschen da, aber auch noch eine Bezugs zu finden.
BRODER Und Adnan wiederum, der kann das besser, weil Der ist aus diesem Sternenreich
der Akoniden sowieso schon als Prinz geboren und hat, war sowieso gewohnt,
so in kosmischen Zusammenhängen zu agieren.
Und dem macht das erst mal wenig aus.
Also der Atlan ist kein Terraner, sondern der ist von den Akoniden.
Genau. Und wenn der 10.000 Raumschiffe in die Schlacht schmeißt,
dann hat er das schon hunderte von Male gesehen.
Und dann weiß er, dass da Millionen von Menschen umkommen. Aber er tut es dann
trotzdem, weil es gemacht werden muss und dann macht er das dann auch und dann
vergeudet er auch keinen einzigen Gedanken mehr über die moralische Implikation,
sondern dann wird das umgesetzt.
Gibt es denn, komme ich jetzt gerade so drauf, hast du so Lieblingsvölker?
Gibt's da irgendwie in dem Universum oder ein Lieblingsraumschiff?
Also es gibt ein tolles Raumschiff, das glaube ich für alle wichtig ist.
Erstmal als Gattung will eigentlich zumindest die Risszeichner finden alle diese
Standard-Kugelraumschiffe der Terraner toll. Sind das die Rauma?
Jedes Raumschiff ist ein Rauma. Das ist ja das Wort, was ich so toll finde.
Aber früher waren standardgemäß wirklich in einem ganz klaren Hierarchie alle
Raumschiffe der Taraner und auch der Arconiden und anderer verwandter Völker
hatten beim Bauartprinzip immer so Kugelraumschiffe mit einem Ringwulst,
in dem die Triebwerksanlagen drin saßen und aus dieser Bauprinzip wurde dann
mal das Kombinationsträgerschiff der Universumsklasse namens Sol geboren.
Das waren nämlich zwei Kugelraumer eben dieser Universumsklasse,
die jeweils 2500 Meter Zellendurchmesse haben und die wurden durch ein zylindrisches
Verbindungsstück von 1500 Meter Höhe zu einem handelförmigen Raumschiff zusammengefügt,
eben das Kombinationsträgerschiff.
Und das ist die sogenannte Sol und die ist über inzwischen viele,
ich glaube schon seit Band 700 in der Heft-Serie.
Und ist gewissermaßen so ein Icon der Serie geworden und ein Generationenschiff,
und hat eine unglaublich verwickelte kosmische Geschichte inzwischen hinter sich.
Okay, ich denke, jetzt haben wir das Thema ganz gut eingepackt.
Perirodern, also auch für euch nochmal neu zu entdecken.
Gibt's jede Woche am Kiosk, gibt's auch im Internet unter Peripedia und ist
auf jeden Fall so ein ganz spezielles deutsches Kulturgut, was nicht jeder kennt.
Auch mir ist es weitgehend verborgen geblieben bisher, muss ich sagen,
aber faszinierend finde ich es trotzdem.
Ja, das war Chaos Radio Express Nummer 35, der Podcast vom Chaos Computer Club.
Wenn ihr Hinweise habt zu diesem Thema, Wünsche für andere Themen,
Kritik, Anregungen oder sonstige Bemerkungen, wie immer gerne per E-Mail chaosradio.ccc.de.
Und wir hören uns sicherlich bald wieder. Ich sag erstmal danke an Gregor.
GREGOR NIEDERHAUSER Ja, danke Tim.
Und ja, das war's und auf Wiedersehen bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.
Tschau.